[Music]
you know
welcome back to the true Geordie podcast
today's guest is Pearl AKA just pearly
just pearly things yeah
um a lot of people know you from hosting
the show where people just seem to lose
it and you get all the heated debates
all the hottest topics in relationships
men against women gender rules
God abortion all sorts of things
um you've really struck under something
and you're getting a reaction from
people what would you describe yourself
as I don't think anyone's ever asked me
that yeah I'm good man good stuff
um I would describe myself as like as a
job or like what what am I like I guess
as a what how do you see yourself in
this space you know because um a lot of
people try and put labels on you oh yeah
and you're the the female this the
female that you know I've seen all sorts
of things um I would say my my content
is a mix between like conservative and
maybe some like red pill topics I would
say um how would you describe red pill
for those who have not got a clue
um it's hard because people use the term
in so many different ways that it's very
confusing um I would say the OG guys in
the space um they would describe it as
the study of human behavior and
basically it was a bunch of guys in like
forums that would talk about issues they
were having like with their girlfriends
or their wives and they would um they
found like similarities between the guys
um and so that's like what the OG guys
but then there's also like the red pill
of seeing the world as it is you know
from The Matrix movie
um and so some people look at it as like
there's like a group of Elites that were
against and you know that whole thing
which I don't want to go to into because
it also seems to be anti-feminist
anti-ruel yeah calling out things for
um like it feels like uh that movement
seemed to have felt like feminine
feminism and walk culture have come into
realign the world in the right way they
thought it should have been and they've
gone too far and now this movement seems
to be pushing back is that fair or not
um I would say the OG guys in the space
would say that's not fair and that the
original point of the red pill movement
was to just the study of human behavior
um however there are other people in the
space that have made it more about
anti-feminism yes and I would probably
put myself as one of them so yeah you
call out stuff
for sure yeah your tweets like they're
explosive and I want to read some of
them because I I went through them last
night just belly laughing at the [__]
you say because I don't agree with
everything but I appreciate yeah how
real you are and it's it's rare to see
anyone be so unsensitive of their own
opinions especially when they're
controversial
why is it that you bring that to the
table like because because
we a lot of people have controversial
opinions but they don't feel like
there's any point in putting it out
there because they can't be bothered
with the hassle yeah um I've just always
been that girl that gave her opinion
when no one asked
I would say a lot of the things I say
are basic and I grew up as just those
are basic like for example
um I always say that and I say this in
no offense to you but my but my mom
always taught me as a woman like you
shouldn't get tattoos yeah and I I felt
like that was like a basic truth like
men don't typically like girls with like
sleeves and
um to me that's just like something I
was grown up with so I'll tweet it and
then people get mad well the the
interesting thing about you is you
you've said things like a woman's places
in the kitchen watching you build a
production company build a business be
the the lady at the Forefront of that
business who people have to listen to
and the boss and then hear you to be
coming up with these old school things
I'm like but your role in your life is
kind of at odds with some of your
opinions is that not right that's
interesting I've gotten that criticism a
lot I wouldn't say it's criticism by the
way well yeah I mean I observation maybe
better
um and I would say yeah I think it's
grow it's blown up a little faster than
I thought and it came with a lot of
problems that I wasn't expecting thing
um and I would say I also have a lot of
room to grow and learn um this last year
I've actually taken it upon myself to to
learn how to cook better I just did a
white we started a second Channel called
wife school where I actually I learned
and so I was kind of I was thinking
about this I was like who else could
figure out how to make it their job how
to be a better wife I love it I do
because I kind of did a lot of the same
I kind of see like what you're doing is
you're taking your interests and you're
turning them into a career just like I
did with boxing or whatever you know so
um I admire your admission of like maybe
I need to learn this I'm just going to
do it in public and and if people want
to share me then so be it like I don't
know this I don't know that yeah
I just did on my wife's School out where
it was like go
so like we went through and like what
what you would cook for like a family of
four because I want four kids so wow
you've really made your mind up I like
it yeah I mean ideally you can't really
yeah and it's weird because you're in a
relationship type uh show where it's
constantly picking apart what men and
women should expect from one another and
where the truth is I would say it's more
like based on the outcomes you want so a
lot of times like as women we we demand
traditional outcomes but we don't have
any traditional skills
so it's like how would you demand that I
don't really care if you want a modern
outcome like that that's not really my
problem like you you live your life how
you want to live your life but if you're
asking for traditional outcomes and you
don't have a traditional resume how are
you supposed to get that and the first
step is admitting you don't have that
and then working on skills to get there
and it does feel like you call people
out on your show uh for kind of wanting
their cake and eat in it yeah a lot a
lot of girls come in with this like well
I won't expect this one not from mine
and you're like okay but what are you
bringing and I've seen girls who thought
they were a 10.
and like one girl in particular there
was a clip that went viral where you
know she was uh what people would
classes over with you know and you you
kind of a whale
yeah she was a bigger whale in it yeah
and look and some men would love that
obviously but like you know she she had
it not really her perception of herself
in reality you you were kind of having
to drop some truth on her in that moment
but not just that there's women who
expect men to have six packs High income
the whole works and you're looking at
them like but what what are you though
and and a lot of times I grew up in a
one percent family so my dad owns a
software company with like 300 200 to
300 people most of my brothers make six
figures and
um I just know like they would never get
in the door not even about I mean that
girl based on her looks but a lot of the
girl a lot of the girls they wouldn't
get in the door based on how they carry
themselves you know what men are looking
for I know what those type of guys are
looking for like again like even even
with the tattoo thing like some guys
want want the girls with the sleeves
they don't have a k they don't care but
like where I'm from that's just not you
know for girls that's not a big thing I
feel bad I feel like I'm picking on you
no no look it's fine it's fine you you
can bully me at this point and I've seen
how you rule the roost but one thing
that does seem to ring true about you is
you seem very aware that men want to be
respected and you have a better
understanding of men than a lot of women
do and you also understand men's
problems with women it's as if you've
been a man and been in a relationship
with a woman you you clearly have done
research where did you come up with this
information a couple different places
one um was my relationship with my my
little brother his name's Adam and me
and Adam we Adam is like what I would
call like a natural like alpha or you
know leader
um Adam it's like his way or the highway
and a lot of my sisters like would
always fight with Adam like Adam was he
just if you don't do it Adam's way and
what I realized this was me and Adam
always got along and we didn't when we
were younger and what switched was I
just started to stop arguing with him
and I just listened to him and took his
opinion what I realized was I was like
he
um was willing to do like more for me
than I realized like he he there's no
one that helps me more like behind the
scenes than my little brother Adam and
my dad and it's because I genuinely like
respect their opinion and listen to them
and it was a really big like turning
point for me in my relationship with
that it was like when I was like 12 so
this was years ago you know but where I
would always argue and like fight with
him then when I just listened to him and
it's also from being on the show where I
just started to realize like a lot of
times girls
we just cap a lot and it's just then I
started to feel like a guy because even
when I was recruiting for the show it
was like the guys would show up on time
the girls we would start the show like
an hour late because all the girls are
like 45 minutes an hour late so
um I would just say it's from partially
from like dealing with women on the show
uh my family and you know past
relationships too I haven't always been
perfect and you know you learn from that
so interestingly blown up in the last
year yeah and the celebrity and all the
[__] that comes with it I mean I've
experienced it and I'm sure that what
you're 26 yeah I'm 26. okay so there's a
lot changing for you right now you're
becoming a big deal how do you think
you're handling that you ask very good
questions you know
um I would say at first
um it was actually not hard for me
um but I would say the bigger I've
gotten it's very hard being like
criticized over like every little thing
and especially from a lot of I found
reaction channels are really just like
looking to take you out of context or
they're just like and it's really not
fair because they're not live and it's
like they have pre-recorded edited stuff
so if they say anything dumb they can
just edit it out and you do long
episodes
correct and I do three sometimes four
I've even done a five I've done a
24-hour live stream are they gonna clip
anything that I said wrong in 24 hours
hours and hours of foot like you're
gonna find something yeah obviously
because you are now
money people can be your friend to get
money people can insult you to get money
that you are on the table nothing is off
limits now and I noticed um recently I
hope you don't mind me bringing this up
because I found it fascinating when I
first discovered you you had another
almost a co-host you were at
um bald-headed guy who was very
articulate very good speaker and I
thought you guys made a good team and he
sort of um you know disappeared from the
channel he then makes a video about you
very recently accusing you of being a
colonizer which I was like you know I'm
not really sure where he's coming from
this and I watched this video does he
look like he has a gun to his head we've
actually got an editor in the room who
happens to also be a black man yeah um
so you know maybe this is evidence no
yeah he has a horrible life he looks
really happy right blessing it's
horrible
and look to summarize the video just for
people who haven't seen it give context
the guy said look on the one hand uh
Pearl's knowledge of the history of
African struggles was very limited and I
had to educate her on how people
colonized he said schooled me he
schooled you yes and then he takes that
he takes that little footage he had of
him explaining something to you about
history yeah and then also then goes I
had a historian actually reach out to me
and say that he was wrong I don't know
I'm not gonna quote it yeah but I did
have a historian like reach out to me
and say like what he said was factually
inaccurate and I was like well I don't
know the thing the thing that made it
strange was that he then linked it to
you then signing up uh content creators
and he basically said you know on the
one hand she didn't know anything about
colonizing and on the other hand she's
trying to sign these people up so
therefore I mean she is a she's a column
and I was like look man you're putting
two and two together and getting five
here you're not even close to the truth
she you are creating an agency this is
what uh you know this is the industry
that music and many many other people
are in with entertainment people spot
Talent they have a platform to boost
that talent and you're actually helping
people
um so I I felt like it was very salty
but it was for me watching you as a
younger Creator and blowing up I was
like this is what happens you know
people if they're not on the gravy train
they'll turn on you very quickly and I
thought it was a shame to say that
happened to you so young yeah no I was
very surprised by that video it was
funny I saw it scheduled earlier in the
day it said the truth about Pearl and I
thought it was going to be him vouching
for me oh no yeah no I really did I I
was on the phone with my dad and I was
like Dad he wouldn't do that plus he's
like twice my age so I'm like he's too
old for this and then the video came out
I was like what like when did yeah and
um yeah that was I was you were friends
right okay I he said we weren't friends
but I met his son so I was like why
would you bring your son to meet me if
we weren't friends yeah and then there
was like clips of him him insinuating
like I wanted something with him and I
was like no like what do you yeah and
then then the weirdest accusation
was the sexual whiteboard parties did
you see that at the end oh yeah where
the NP said is it it it basically
there's a cliffhanger which I was like I
mean I rate the creativity of it because
he made it look like you were guys were
having like orgies like [__] Playboy
Mansion sober at that point I was so mad
it was like um oh my gosh it was so
funny because one he put in videos of
two producers that like like um blessing
like he people know kind of know who he
is but he's not on camera and some
people don't want to be on camera so he
put people in that video that like
weren't a part of this you know and then
the funny thing was it was like the
tamest party ever it was um we gave
everybody the big white board right and
we said you can do a speech on anything
and you know uh my speech was the ways
that men cap yeah because I was like I'm
always on on the whim and today I'm
switching teams you know yeah so I was
like today yeah and then he just took
that and like ran with it I guess well
he made it a race issue which I think
considering your channel is you know
it's from people from all backgrounds
consistently it just and I thought
you're gonna have to have some hard
evidence here and he had nothing no I I
don't know why he did that um I could I
could speculate but I I wish him well I
hope he you know the fact that you're so
gracious about it was surprising I hope
he does his thing I wish he didn't I was
a quite Rude video if I may say so
myself a lot of false accusations but I
mean yeah maybe in a few years there'll
be you'll be more uh prone to get a
lawyer out when those things happen I
don't know because that's how things
change unfortunately yeah I mean there
is some legal stuff going on that I
can't really talk too much about but
yeah we're on it you got banned from
Tick Tock right what was that for Homer
has five times wow I'll tell you the
original band I've just got on Tick Tock
so I thought I'd be aware of this yeah
yeah you can't call women whales yeah so
this is a problem yes I've already
clipped that yeah yeah so my first go
ahead I don't care so my first um Tick
Tock I almost had to do a million
followers because I was on Tick Tock
before YouTube
that's what I've kind of blown up on
shorts because I've done it before on
Tick Tock so when I went to YouTube I
killed the shorts game you know what I
mean so
um on uh Tick Tock there was a video
that I call this the whale attack I've
spoken about this before so I'm doing my
street interviews and this lady who
who's I'm not gonna you know insult her
and go up about her looks
but she was a whale yeah so if I had to
if I had to use words too as well we're
talking about security I'm walking home
alone at night and I just can't stand
the women that are like oh my God I
can't walk home alone at night I'm like
okay neither can nobody can you seem
like you would be fine the walking home
alone I think you might be like even you
know if there's enough people you're
[__] it doesn't matter how big you are
right yeah yeah
likely to be victims of a violent crime
so I was just like nobody can walk home
alone at night like maybe and this is
what I I was I'm solution minded so I
said why don't you just not live in a
big city that's dangerous and not walk
home alone uh no I'm not I'm you know
what I live in the same city and there's
sometimes I don't walk home alone
because I'm scared and and she didn't
like this so she just started freaking
out and she's like I'll have you you
slag I'll have you now I didn't know
what a swag meant at the time okay
because I'm American so we don't use I
guess that's [__] is that right [__]
which I was like rude now and so because
she kept calling me a slag I was like
whatever you're a whale and so because
oh you've said a lot to her yeah yeah
but she started it she called me like
you know most of the time when I do call
these women whales they call me
something first I am I am responding I
do say the whales in generalities I
could probably cut back on that but I
think it's funny so I yeah I keep doing
it so anyways so this girl came at me
and then because I I when I put the
captions on this video they I woke up my
account was banned I'm gonna bring up
some of the tweets that you've tweeted
because I think they're great
conversations sometimes sometimes I I
don't think a lot before these tweets no
we don't want to hear your excuses
make excuses after all right okay she's
getting them in quickly okay no I think
this is quite a poignant topic because
it's really big right now in America
especially and you are obviously uh from
America so saying biological men compete
in women's sports makes me so sad it's
actually disgusting oh yeah I meant that
yeah and you see this woman swimmer
right now who's getting chased in her
own University is she I love her
I love her I'm a fan
um yeah I know I think it's sad um I
played I don't know if you know this but
I was recruited here to play volleyball
yeah so that's why I'm here and
um I have never had to compete against
the guy but I swear to God if I did I
would protest I would oh you would love
that I think you would actually be like
now is my chance
no one would be happier than you would I
would be like let's film everything this
girl actually to be fair to her I think
she did make some really fair points
like she stood up and said like I have
spent my whole life pretty much training
for this moment and that's that's what
they don't understand like I don't know
anyone I
like I've trained for 16 years
um to get to a point where I could play
at this level and it's like what we
don't get money out of it you know I'm
not mad that we get paid less because
less people watch it and so when you
sell less tickets you don't make as much
money but at the end of the day like I
can think of my volleyball career in 16
years there's maybe like three
championships that I'm really proud of
like we went to State and high school
and um we went to the ncaas twice in
college so that's three moments in 16
years and if I had to compete against
the biological man that's just not fair
come back to some of your tweets because
I do want to keep going on these are
fantastic
why does a man have to use his life
savings to fight for his kids when it's
50 his deity why isn't he automatically
given custody 50 yeah no I think it's
actually disgusting what they do in the
court system here I'm doing a
documentary um on the court system in
the UK oh my God it's actually
disgusting
um the more I learn about it there were
women are incentivized to claim that a
man like abused I just had a girl on the
show that said that they got um they
know someone that got free housing
because they went to a women's shelter
and said they were abused and she wasn't
even in a relationship in 2013 when they
implemented that law where they get free
counsel abuse allegations went up 200
percent why are we rewarding women for
claiming abuse a guy I know
um had uh like Financial issues and he
had to pay for all of his ex's court
fees so he's struggling financially and
she gets all of her um legal like
letters and everything paid for by him
so if she wanted and she wanted to be
vindictive she could ring her lawyer up
every day for a month and every single
phone call every single letter goes on
his bill well and they'll kicked the man
out of the house with their with the
men's name on the mortgage so they're
still paying their mortgage and a house
they're kicked out of like this guy I
talked to the other day he didn't get to
go to court for a year and a half
so he like he didn't see his kids for a
year and a half and he couldn't fight it
because of kovid like it pushed all the
court dates back and um she accused him
of abuse even though the kid was a mile
away so a mile away he could he had no
rights to his kids and then
um on top he ended up homeless and
losing his job because he he worked in
electricity so it you know I mean
imagine one day you're just you know
chilling with your wife by the TV then
you go one phone call and now she's
kicked you out of the house the whole
Community thinks you're an abuser and on
top of that um now you have to pay child
support and he doesn't even get a day in
court another thing that really
surprised me from this guy I was talking
to was he with him being low on money if
he has enough money to support himself
and uh his ex then she doesn't get a
council house but if she takes him to
court and Blades him dry and leaves him
penniless she then gets the council
house so again she is incentivized to
bankrupt her ex well and then I always
hear the the Trad like the more
conservatives like they'll come out at
them and be like well man it's because
the men aren't fighting in court and I'm
like well would would you fight in court
if you would at 10 chance of winning and
also the more that if the so in the
event of it going to court yeah you are
going to lose so much money correct so
you're literally being told right you're
either settle out of court for an
extortionate amount of money or go to
court and pay double that meanwhile
there is no risk on the woman's side at
all it's the most sexist thing I've ever
seen in my life and there's no penalty
either for her like what if she she does
all that and you get the kids is there a
penalty does she then have to pay all
your questions and I I heard um this was
before I really studied the system I
used to not understand I'm like why
would not a man not fight for his kids
exactly like that's I literally used to
think that and I used to like look down
um and also on homeless people like I
was like how could you end up homeless
you're like in your 40s or 50s like
you've had so much time and then I
realized a lot of these guys that are
homeless have just been like wrecked in
the court system because imagine like if
you're 40 or 50. it's not like you're
going to be able to start over from
scratch and really get to where you
don't have the energy you have you can
be blackmailed as a man legally you can
so a woman can literally say to you you
either buy me a house or I'll take you
to court I'll bleed you dry leave you
with nothing and then I'll get a council
house so you're [__] either way and
you're just sitting there like and and
so it to me when I hear about these guys
that are like you know what I'll talk to
the kid when they turn 18. it's it's
really sad but I understand where
they're coming from because what else is
he supposed to do yeah and the sad thing
is too a guy could go through all of
this right and maybe he doesn't get
primary great custody and he only gets
um and he gets the kids six days a month
which is a win right weekends for for a
guy that's a win and and like half of
holidays I think that's more standard
whatever it is to think that's a win
yeah and I know that's that's the sad
part and and she can just make a call
and do the same thing all over again and
accuse him of be of abuse all over again
so even if he wins and he will have to
pay for the phase again correct and so
it's like guys are just more logical
like women were emotional we're like
fight for your kids come on like why
would you not but from a man's point of
view it's like I'm gonna fight and yet
unless I get unless he gets primary
custody which is 10 of the time she has
all the power I mean and like let's be
real foreign she has to be a crackhead
crack yes yeah so I I read something
that hookers are more likely to get
custody of their social I don't I don't
quote me that might not be true but I
don't think
like dirt you know we are dogs in the in
in in the eyes of the law and it's I I
really appreciate a woman standing up
for us in that respect because men are
just voiceless and you see these fathers
for justice and you know they're trying
to make a stand but they they ain't got
hope right now you know they need help
that's who I've been working with
actually on the documentary I've been
interviewing a lot of them yeah it's
really sad and it shows in society how
they don't act like we need fathers even
women when you talk about their backup
plan if they don't have kids it's IVF
that is the most selfish thing I've ever
heard you're gonna choose to be a single
mother like you don't think you need a
dad I mean you could do it it doesn't
make it a good idea you know like I
think it's selfish I think it goes back
to like the me me culture where it's me
before the family I want a kid so bad
that I'm going to put my best interests
instead of the kids instead of I don't
know lowering your standards well you
know you're opening up a whole load of
different topics there which I think are
fascinating like what is for a man there
is no incentive for marriage anymore
there is none none yeah why I mean this
bad part is like all of the risks that
come with marriage from what from what
I'm learning is that you really can't
avoid them if you have a child like like
the kid really isn't yours it's really
hers legally and I understand that women
obviously like make the decision to give
life so I understand that the part of
the logic but we've got no rights like I
I don't fair enough weight to the woman
but give us something I wouldn't even
say like I just think it's 50 his DNA
it's half his kid it should be 50. I
mean if he's paying all the money
especially which many men are not not
old but many men are covering all the
bills and everything post the
relationship and yet they get they get
nothing for it yeah I think a lot of men
even if it didn't work out would they
they want to take care of their kids you
know um I I just don't really believe
this like deadbeat dad narrative I think
a lot of times it's like more women not
letting men access their kids then we
really give credit to unfortunately
children do become used as a pawn in the
game and that is the most common thing
let's not act like it isn't it's very
common one thing I found really
interesting for watching your show that
I became more aware of is the statistics
and the changing of the the date in game
right now and how
um I think I I don't know if the stats
are right but like how women are now
less and less are getting married less
and less having children before the age
of 30 and there's a bit of a crisis
there in um you know people aren't
settling down the way they used to why
do you think that is I think women are
delusional I think a lot of girls like
we think we're hotter than we are and we
think we have more leverage than we do
when really like by and large as women
we offer less than we did in previous
generations just my opinion
um and I think listen how about what
we're sorry I think women tend to want
traditional men and I think men tend to
want traditional women you know I know
there's outliers in this but I think by
and large like women are attracted to
more traditional men men are attracted
to more traditional women but like by
and large like how many women virgins
are there how many virgin brides are
there nowadays yeah how many women like
have a cookbook know how to cook from
scratch how many women
um would delete their Instagram because
their husband told them to without
arguing or even delete certain
photographs yeah and you you comment a
lot about women who post like semi-nude
images on their Instagram and that sort
of thing well you know what's
interesting
um okay do you think this is true
because in order for me to ask this
question you have to believe this is
true do you think attention is to women
is what like sex is to men like women
want attention you're close on that for
sure not every woman but yeah I think
there's definitely in general there's a
link that women are seeking attention
men are seeking sex so it's interesting
because if you get into a relationship
you're expected to stop sleeping with
other people but the woman's not
expected to delete Instagram you know
the men are looked at as dogs if they
cheat right but but the women are not
looked at as dogs if they have a
provocative picture on their Instagram
and if anything they'll die trying to
defend it so it's just not it's not
really a fair exchange when you think
about it it is a problem in in
relationships like for men we're
noticing like guys still liking those
photographs and it makes you feel like
she doesn't respect you she doesn't
she's keeping the door open in case
other men come along that's mentally how
we feel you know if I was Instagram I
was looking at freaking um Haley beavers
I was like how are you married to Justin
Bieber and you still have provocative
pictures on your Instagram I know she's
a model but I'm like you got Justin
Bieber you can't put that away yeah and
he doesn't seem like he even cheats on
her with the new Christian thing you
know that he might I don't know you know
we're not gonna
but my point is she got like that was
that was the guy that I mean it wasn't
my thing in high school but like every
girl wanted Justin Bieber and it's like
you got him and you still got pictures
in your underwear on Instagram back in
the day it would have just been like get
that [__] thing off you know what I
mean you're not you're not what like me
like save a woman was about to go on a
night out wearing provocative clothing
men in my dad's day and his dad's they
would have been like no [__] way now
the the script has been flipped and now
it's like we don't want them to know we
like them too much so we're having to
pretend like we're cool with that and
we're playing this game in our head like
acting like yeah I'm fine with it I'm
comfortable but reality is like they're
not no it doesn't make them feel fine
and when they say men drop in fire
emojis underneath these pictures of
their like Scotty clad girlfriends it's
[__] with their heads yeah because
that's the guy that's going to be in the
DMS as well well and the men are shamed
for it they're called you controlling
and jealous you're a control freak yeah
yeah I'm just like for not wanting your
tits on Instagram like get out of here
oh that's so crazy yeah whatever but no
but that's the narrative that's been
created and if you challenge that it's
easier to Gaslight you than to disprove
you
and that's where your then as a lot of
these men out there because not every
man is strong enough to stand up to a
woman that they're loving and they don't
want to let go and they feel lucky to
have such a beautiful woman so therefore
they're like you know maybe maybe she is
right maybe I am just a controlling and
maybe I do need to work on me you know
what I mean but the reality is is like
it's only natural to want to have a bit
of respect in a relationship and not put
everything out there that's supposed to
be for each other right I suppose we
won't be expecting that from you anytime
soon no
no in a way now you've kind of made a
rod for your own back because you kind
of you've set the bar as to what you
think women should be so publicly that
if you ever slip people are going to be
on you I know I know
I like it though I like I like the
challenge yeah you gotta stay like
strict with yourself I'm a competitor so
well I I see that I'm an athlete a
couple of uh other
um things that you've tweeted out which
I found funny a girl doesn't sleep with
one man and become a [__] a girl
chooses to sleep with multiple men to
become a [__] the common denominator is
the woman I'm so tired of us being not
owning bad decisions yes oh my gosh
because every oh my gosh every time on
my show
can be riled up they would say okay I
would be we were talking about like if a
girl sleeps around she's a [__] right I
I felt like that's basic okay that's
like like I don't even think that's
controversial and like you know some
people will argue what the number is
right like some some guys will will say
over to [__] so some guys will say over
10. you know the most common number I
get is ten okay that's that just from
doing I don't really care I'm not here
to argue at what point right but by and
large the more women are men a woman
sleeps with the more of a horse she is
okay and and then the women will always
say but what about the men the men sleep
around okay okay but again again the
common denominator is you like it's one
thing if you get bamboozled by one guy
okay we're not gonna pretend that
there's no men that take advantage of
women okay like we're not gonna pretend
there's no players but how players did
you meet
make the okay like now let's let's say
let's say 5 is the number of Horrors so
you met five players five not one not
you didn't learn your lesson the first
second third for fourth no no ma'am
that's you you can't you're just not a
victim do you think one excuse that
these girls could have and I'm certainly
not you know I don't don't know which
side of this I've fallen right now but
the date in game has changed because of
internet dating so dramatically in my
opinion that men have taken the control
of like they just expect sex from the
jump so now if you're a woman who's
holding out it's a lot harder to keep a
man interested when the the power is now
more with the men than it's ever been
and the expectation of sex is more
higher than it's ever been so for a
woman to keep a man interested long
enough to know if he's going to be a
serious Contender you kind of are not
force but more inclined to give them
that because you don't want to go along
to the next girl because he's going to
get it there anyway he wants it I think
that's a fair argument for the small all
percentage of men that are getting
screwed by multiple girls but I think
for most cases I think in most cases The
Leverage is actually with the women
because most men aren't getting laid
well I mean that was the start that I
sort of I can't remember one out of
three men are either virgins or haven't
had sex in the past year under 30. and
then there's this like 80 20 thing that
I keep hearing the number one way that
people like date now is from online
dating and women only swipe right five
percent of the time so if you go on a
date with someone online like he's he's
the one getting all the matches because
you matched with him so he's probably in
the top five percent of men
so that means if I had like a lot of
swipes that means I'm pretty desirable
yeah yeah
I mean um you you pretty successful
podcast I'm sure you're in the top like
what 10 of income how tall are you six
full six four so you're in the top um so
only ten percent of men are over six
foot so I don't I don't know what six
four is but that's so income you're
probably top five percent boom height
you're probably top five percent so yeah
you could kill it out here on these
streets
so this is the problem for women though
right so competing for a guy like you
yeah they probably would so you know and
I don't really fault people for wanting
what they want like if a girl wants to
be single and childless okay go do it
you go after your career I don't care
but it's like don't complain later so if
you want to compete for those guys
that's a choice right like a girl
competing for you that's a choice so you
you might have to but I also think men
are willing to wait if they think it's
genuine the issue the issue with like
guys nowadays is they just don't think
it's genuine because they're like what
you're a virgin at 28
like why am I waiting like that that's I
think that's how guys have told me they
see it yeah but we had like a girl that
was a virgin on our show that I actually
genuinely believed and she has no
problem having high value guys
interested in her because it's genuine
yeah I did meet one girl who was uh an
older version of late 20s and I just
remember being like oh you are really
playing this hard the hard game you know
looking for the prince yeah I had um I
had a what do you call it a video called
your virginity doesn't count if
and and one of them was like if you're
over a certain age I think guys start to
think well why are you a virgin like
have none of the men met your standards
is something wrong with you a million
percent things yeah yeah I think there's
a happy medium and once you hit 25 and
over men are like yeah yeah do you not
like how can you just like I immediately
would have thought you can't be that
into sex because at some point the urges
are going to take over no matter how
sensible you are or she was really
overweight when she was younger that's
the other thing it doesn't count if
you're fat like no one you want like
trying so for you then you know you're a
tall girl women tend to like men taller
women tend to like men who make more
money than them is that would you say
that's fair yeah that is fair you're
you're really [__] all right now I'm
sorry no my stats are so bad because
you're a guy owner and you're tall yeah
I know do you think I'm gonna have to
compromise yeah no I definitely will
um I've gone for guys shorter than me
yeah so I mean
men love taller girls as well guys don't
care yeah they don't give a [__] I mean
I can't do like I don't want to say cat
but it would be tough for me if it's
like crazy but I'm like six foot so
um I don't know like five nine it's okay
yeah we're letting them know yeah and in
terms of like income and stuff like that
that's another thing that women have
been big on on your podcast like they've
said like I want guys who are on six
figures and I feel like it's hard for me
to judge because it's like yeah I make
good income now but it's an internet who
knows how long this will last and it's
like what I talk into a microphone so
I'm better than a construction worker
yeah it's like boy because I talk all
right more tweets uh I some of these are
just so [__] funny strippers or
[__] oh yeah yeah I did tweet that
yeah I did a show on that too I mean
there was another one where it was um
the only fans girls as well that you
basically call them out oh my gosh I was
so excited because um what's his face
tweeted at me
um Logan Paul's friend Mike say a lot
yeah I triggered him I was like I
triggered Mike I'm like it's not my
fault you dated Lana Rhodes seriously
like you did that anyways
um but yeah um I just thought it would
be funny to just tweet basic things and
see if people argued and then everyone
was arguing with me they were like oh
well a stripper might have a lower body
count than your average girl and I'm
just like okay but she's still selling
her boobs for money and getting naked
like what else do you call that you
obviously come from like I've seen some
of your family photographs like you come
from what looked like a very wholesome
family background so to you like I I
assume have you ever talked with people
like that like only fans girls strip us
yeah and what is it like for you when
you are saying these things and then
then you're meeting people and finding
more about their real lives and how
because you said earlier you had an uh
an opinion of homeless people that was
then sort of explained did you have any
Epiphany when you meet these girls or
not I think some of them are in bad
situations and that's why they do it but
I still have
very little sympathy to be honest
because
um a lot of men are put in those same
situations and they're just homeless
like at least women we have an out I
personally don't mind like strippers and
horse that accept their outcomes my
issue is when they start whining that
men don't want to date them it's like
what did you expect you know pick your
pick your poison pick your battle the uh
I think obviously there are some men who
will date only fans girls but like like
I wouldn't even pay for one of the funds
yeah you know I I think men who do that
you know you need to go out loud why
would you your top five percent hey but
also like only fans tricks they are
picking a certain Road and and with Lana
she is a great example because she
picked the porn Road made millions and
then at the end of her porn career
denounced porn said it was horrible said
it was this said it was that said it was
the other and then I recently had a porn
star on my podcast a male porn star who
worked with her who said she wasn't like
that on set she was quite happy
fine she got trapped like royalty you
know so for her to go up and denounce it
because she's now being [__] shamed it's
because of the outcome she's blaming the
process because it's easier to be a
victim than it is to just hold your
hands up and go I've picked this road
and now at my bed ironically and I have
to lie in it and I think you've got a
point to be honest yes I respect the
ones I had one girl on the Auntie you
know the one that Auntie interviewed she
was so cool she was a stripper and she
came on Auntie's show she like
interviewed her one-on-one
and she's just like yeah I made these
choices these are the outcomes
that's it she's not whining about what
the outcomes I just don't like whiners
look one of my generalizations and one
of my favorite tweets from you is I I
generalize and I will continue to
generalize but one of mine is like in
the with the women I've met and [__] me
I can't believe I'm saying this but here
we go
they don't like being wrong you know and
they don't take kindly to being told
they're wrong and whereas you're a woman
doing that to them you're literally
putting and [__] me I wonder why um I
wonder what would have happened in your
career if you'd have been a guy and
you'd have come up with all these
opinions you'd have been lynched
your head would be on a stick outside of
my Palace in the Buckner Palace yeah I
certainly have an advantage because I'm
a woman I think a lot of people like to
see people like speak on things why do
you think accountability and being told
they're wrong is such a trigger for a
lot of women I think we don't really see
the world for what it is in a way until
we're a certain age because
because bad decisions so it's like
everybody every decision we make there's
a bailout so if you want to sleep around
in the old days you get pregnant by the
wrong guy now you got a shotgun wedding
you're stuck for life nowadays birth
control now if birth control fails and
you do get pregnant by the wrong guy
which some of you ladies I just don't
understand how you do that like a
million times but that's not my battle
now now then what what happens next you
can get an abortion for free you don't
even got to pay for it here so now or
you can give birth and give the kid up
for adoption or you can be single live
your best life and put them on child
support I also think that women are like
we're treated better in the world and
we're given more help by men generally
um just because we're young women and
that I think does go away a little bit
the older you get you know the less like
attractive you are there is a
correlation there and even like let's
say we're bad with money
um we can get free assistance from the
government benefits and if we get
homeless there's women's shelters and
then we can just claim abuse for a
boyfriend we don't have and get a free
apartment I just think a lot of times
whenever we have to take accountability
for a decision like how do you learn
accountability there's bad outcomes
there's consequences but for women like
we don't really have consequences for
much for bad with money we're bad
sexually like and you'll probably still
get married even if like even cornstars
get sorry if we say corn porn stars get
married oh it's not from The Tick Tock
thing yeah because you you did Colin
just to stop you from getting blocked or
whatever yeah I don't I just heard it
wasn't good on YouTube
good idea I should have thought of that
before I had to view the porn star yeah
but in terms of abortion you've been
quite vocal about that that's quite an
interesting one yeah I'm very pro-life
what is it about abortion that you feel
uncomfortable about I have a personal
anecdote to it where I've been on both
sides of adoption so my parents had six
kids growing up I was the second out of
the six I was the oldest girl they
adopted three teenagers one teenager
they adopted when I was like a baby she
moved out so I didn't really grow up
with her two teenagers they adopted
after I left for college I didn't grow
up with them but they lived with us for
a couple years three teenagers so that's
nine when I was 22 my parents sat us
down in a room
um we were somewhere at a wedding I
think and they look at us and they say
um you have a brother and his name is
Greg
and my mom actually got pregnant when
she was 17.
and they gave that kid up for adoption
um same parents a lot of people think
different parents know same dad
um but they were just young they just
started dating and they gave them up for
adoption and I actually met him when he
was in his 30s I was 22 or 23 when I
first met him and it was crazy how
similar he was to us like he walked like
my brothers he was had the same sense of
humor he grew up in a small town in the
middle of like rural Wisconsin and
um he owned like a sailboat company and
like sailed around the world and my
family is very adventurous and his
parents like had never left left their
Hometown and that's how crazy it was
like he was just like us even though we
had we didn't talk to him until he was
like 30.
and
um so that experience just kind of made
me pro-life because I feel like my mom
could have had an abortion and it would
have been a shame because now he just
became a dad he just got married and I
genuinely do believe it's a child I
think if people were pulling
um surgically
oh if they were opening up dogs and
surgically pulling off the limbs one by
one and then crushing the skull and
vacuuming it out I think people would be
outraged but some reason when we do that
with women
you know
um nobody talks about it and it a lot of
people don't know
um that when there's a unique DNA
sequence that starts from conception and
that has um the baby's like eye color
hair color personality trait like that's
from conception I'm not going to pretend
like I'm a doctor like I know the ins
and outs of it but I just yeah I just
don't believe in abortion and I think
there's too many options and resources
for women to be getting abortions and I
think it's crazy because it's legal up
to six months and um yeah it's here you
can get it for free up to six months and
there's children that have survived
before that and like if you look up
videos I genuinely think everyone would
be pro-life if they saw a video of an
abortion because literally like imagine
up like a five-month-old child you're
which is mostly developed and they
literally pull the limb off pull the leg
off pull the arm off pull the middle out
and then they crush the skull and vacuum
it out and that's not good for women
either like I don't a lot they'll say
it's like a woman's right to choose
acting like this is something that's
going to help us when I know women that
are traumatized from having an abortion
we had a girl um that came on our show
and she even talked about how here she
didn't know that when she like she took
the pill which is like an earlier one
and she said she didn't realize how
developed the kid was she thought it was
a fetus and it came out and it was like
she's like it had a hat it had fingers
and it was like traumatizing for her I
could see you're really passionate about
this and also I could see there where
you were talking about your brother like
how much that meant to you and it's nice
that it's not just like
I know you like to be controversial but
I can see that you're speaking from a
place of like real empathy there and uh
a lot of women speak about what happens
if they are attacked and impregnated Etc
um what do you say to those people
because that would be something that
people are saying at the screen now well
um it's a really small percentage of
cases anyway I mean the data they kind
of hide the data on abortion it's not
very well collected but in the states
that they have collected in the US it's
less than one percent of cases so um a
lot of times like people kind of use
that as a cop-out in my opinion anyway
because it's like you're arguing for one
percent of cases what about the other 99
but I I don't believe in abortion ever I
think it's really sad when that happens
I think I could even go as far
I don't want to like die on this opinion
but the death penalty for rapists to be
honest um that are actually convicted
like the issue you would get into is
that false accusations all that stuff
you know but if there's a way to prove
he did it and it actually happened then
I could go as far to suggest the death
penalty for rapists but I just don't
think you can take that out on a child
like that the kid's innocent what did
the kid do and I think it goes back to
the the real opinion you have to have is
do you think it's a kid or do you not
think it's a kid
if you don't think it's a kid I
understand like the the people's opinion
on it because like why would there be
any problem if it's not a kid but if you
think it's a kid if it's not a kid what
is it is the question yeah I do
understand if someone is a victim of an
attack wanting to not go through with
giving birth with that child given you
know to raise the the the attacker's
child it's a hell of a an even just to
even give it a production is a lot but I
overall I understand the other side of
that like if you know if this is some
people will just use it as a form of
contraception and which is insane
there's a girl that had seven abortions
Jesus I think 40 of women that get
abortions have had two or more
so it's just women getting them over and
over I mean what's the best predictor of
future Behavior past Behavior so a lot
of the women like half of the women
getting abortions not their first have
you ever had an issue with saying this
to people like because I can imagine you
could trigger someone with this level of
oh yeah
um
absolutely I've had people
friends with me over
yeah it was really hurtful
because you come across bulletproof
right you're very calm I've seen people
challenge you but like you are you know
you're a woman you're pretty femininity
you know there must be moments where
you're not the the boss you know what I
mean that you come across like no um I
would say I actually am pretty emotional
to be honest
um I don't
I mean I'm smart I don't put it on
camera you know um but no I had a friend
of 20 years stop being friends with me
um over this stuff and then she came out
and put like videos out about me I
didn't really want to give it too much
attention but
um yeah it's really sad to be honest
when you say it I'm small I don't put it
on camera why what what would you mean
smart why you can't respond too much to
like trolls and like hater otherwise
you're giving them power you know
because they see that they can react to
you and then they make money and then
they just keep going so it's like if
they see you get emotional and they see
you like that they have an effect on you
they're just gonna keep going
um yeah and I just kind of look at it
like a job in a way or do you cry at
work it's probably not good to cry at
work yeah I I always think if someone
doesn't know you personally don't take
it personally yeah because they just
yeah like there was this chick who was
um you actually quoted the Tweet like
she there was a video that she made
about you where she was psychoanalyzing
you and then she was like playing with
she wouldn't do this well I get men to
come and all this crazy and you just
literally caught it like she's crazy
just laughed yeah no she's nutty the
harder ones have been the people that I
know that have turned I would say
um that I didn't really expect when
crazy women offer their crazy opinions I
really don't care like I just think
they're stupid to be honest like you're
telling me I'm gonna take the opinion
seriously of a woman who's like going
like this I'm okay like let me just get
take everyone's opinion though
and uh I mean like she was an only fans
check I think so she obviously had a
vested interested
now she said she did say that but I I
was just laughing at you you're tweeting
her but one thing that you did say in
regards to birth control and and that
sort of thing on Twitter was I think
this is a very interesting question of
can a man fully consent to sex if the
woman lies about being on birth control
yeah because the women always say they
can't like you can I think you can file
in some states
um again I can say right right yeah I
mean okay we might just you know I don't
know but you can um say that a guy raped
you if he took off the condom and you
didn't notice
um so did you rape him if you say you're
on the pill and you're not that's my
question
um because when you think about it when
we have sex there's only one party I
mean minus the the
exception they're gonna be like what if
you don't see the condoms I'm like
really you did okay fine but but there's
only one only the women get all the
information about the size X because
they we know if we're ovulating or not
or you should anyways
um you know if you're on birth control
or not and you assuming it's consensual
you pick who you sleep with where the
men it's like their their options are
condom or no condom vasectomy or no
vasectomy and the women also have plan B
abortion dot like all those other stuff
I was listing before so women have all
the information men don't that's why men
get like Bamboozled into children
they're like I thought she was on birth
control
careful top five percent
genuinely that's yeah that's a real
thing where like surprise you know it
the like there is no way that the day uh
like wouldn't buckle up like accidental
pregnancies being more common with rich
men than than poor guys well when you
think about it girls only ovulate like
what three days four days maybe five
total in a month but I think there's
only like two or three days you can it's
really likely you'll get pregnant so
when people say like oh it was an
accident I'm like I I'm just a little
skeptical tell that to Drake yeah oh
yeah like come on she was probably like
okay I'm ovulating this yeah she's
texting him slowly because for those who
don't know Drake got you know had a kid
with a girl who was basically on video
dancing naked and whatever else well and
a lot of these women are predatory um I
just did an interview with the guy and
he talked about how like women will book
out towels by and like NBA players right
and these women go to these games with
the express purpose of trying to get
these men to cheat on their wives like
he talked about one girl that he like
dated later and that she was so proud
she's like it took me two years but I
finally slept with that it was like a
professional hockey player she's like he
said he would never cheat on his wife
and I got him too like they they like
take pride in that there's like women
that like they they're Predators they
they know everything about these men so
you think you're running into a you're
21 years old guy you just got in the
league you think oh this that girl at
the bar is so nice she knows exactly
what you want to hear she knows all your
interests she knows everything about you
and you just think oh she's a nice girl
you know and these women know how to
present themselves in a way that like
makes them seem like the girl next door
oh they make you feel like a king yeah
yeah that's the problem is men we're the
Chaser no you know what I mean so it's a
very strange thing then men just think
the best of the situation because they
aren't women have been told from day one
like saying no to boys and all of that
you know that was never yeah well I mean
we're all women I just think are viewed
as innocent and I think men just have
that they haven't you guys have an
innate protect like we want to trust you
yeah we want to and and I think you guys
have an innate like you like you want to
protect us too naturally and I think
women know that and there's certain
women that take advantage of it and like
how how common we'd always talk about
the player man we never talk about the
Predator women I mean in my space we do
but not overall on the media yeah yeah I
think one of the things that surprised
me about women the older I got was how
women could
reframe things and and and so like
you'll find yourself arguing with a
woman and
you realize it's a competition of who
can claim victim you know like oh but
you did that no but you did that first
but then you did that and what led to
this do you know what I mean and like
it's like [__] hell I can't just be
the I can't get a sorry for if my life
depended on it yeah there ain't no sorry
it's coming to me like have you ever
seen those videos of like girls trying
to justify their cheating like they got
caught cheating and then they start
crying I'm like [__]
why are you crying
snake I saw this video this guy and it
could be fake you know that but but
things go viral because people relate to
it right otherwise people wouldn't
believe it and she'd screwed like three
guys while they were dating she's like
well you probably cheated on me too and
it's just like okay can we talk about
what you did first that my thing is like
I've I've gotten sorries from a woman in
a heated argument and then I've been
like and then immediately afterwards
comes all of the justifications and I'm
like you're sorry doesn't mean anything
anymore because you've said sorry and
then now you're telling me why it was
really my fault the whole time I'm sorry
but yeah yeah if I hear but after sorry
I'm like that what the [__] are we doing
there you know this ain't over we're
just still going you know what I didn't
understand
learned about man as men really don't
like when you say why
like when when you when they tell you
something and you're like but why why
like I didn't realize how annoying that
is to guys because we're just like nosy
or you know we just want to know we want
to be in the know and I didn't realize
realize sting that is to guys to just
have to explain every little thing well
yeah because
and luckily I think in this red pill
space that they are realizing like
they're coming out with a lot of things
like men are looking for respect and
peace yeah and if we don't get that
we will never be happy
it's women think it's about love and
that's part of it but it ain't all of it
you know what I mean and if we're
constantly being challenged questioned
and and not feeling like our opinion is
valid or matters then we will be in a
relationship thinking I want out and I
want someone who does do those things
for me yeah and that was actually one of
like the turning points I had with my
brother that like I was talking about
earlier was he I didn't realize that he
felt like
um you know that was disrespectful to
him and always asking and asking and
asking instead of just listening
old-fashioned men it correct me if I'm
wrong because obviously you know these
kind of guys it's like generally we let
women have their opinion on almost
everything but when our foot's down then
it needs to ma because if that if that
doesn't matter then then where is our
power what do we what do we we're giving
you you want the walls pink I'll paint
the walls pink you want the [__]
corporate screen you know what I mean
but like if if I put my foot down it
needs to matter but like it feels like
modern women really haven't grasped that
out tell you something I think that the
laws have changed how we interact in
relationships we always hear the phrase
happy wife happy life she wears the
pants right those are common right very
common and would you you could would you
agree or disagree that more women lead
than men lead nowadays in relationships
one million percent yes okay and I think
about why that is
coming yeah go ahead men taking women's
last names or babies taking women and
women and men double barrel the names
like the old the old ways of like a man
being the head of the family even a name
is not the same anymore
and and I question why and this actually
came from one of the fathers for justice
guys that I interviewed and he was
saying it changes the way we interact in
relationships because think about it
okay if me and you are married right and
if I leave I get everything and you
leave and you lose everything you're
always going to be trying to make it
work oh yeah and I'm always going to
have one foot out the door and even if
we're not married we just have a kid
it's the same thing the men have more
incentive to make it work where the
women have more incentive to leave which
is why by and large and you know there's
exceptions there's guys that get good
prenups or figure out you know ways
around it whatever but by and large in a
society like the men are always going to
be trying to please the women because
even if they don't know all the stuff
about the laws I think men still
innately know they lose more than she
does
and women innately know that we get more
because we've seen someone get screwed
over in divorce like you don't know
anyone you're a shitty wife if you don't
honor your husband and respect his
leadership and then you said you're a
shitty wife if you don't sleep with your
husband yes and this is like basic you
know because what's the opposite of that
dishonoring are you a good wife if you
dishonor your husband
sleep with him for five years like
that's what men want it's like the one
thing well one of your next tweets was
kind of piggybacking off of that which
is is it more common for women to get
far after marriage or for men to stop
working after marriage
what are you getting out there just just
to understand that because the women
right
kids and I don't and I've said this I I
don't think men expect our bodies to be
exactly the same as when we were 25 okay
like that guys are reasonable however
they didn't expect you to gain a hundred
pounds Diane like like they didn't
expect he didn't expect that and so it's
like and then the girls will be like oh
he's out of shape too but I'm like he's
still probably providing more than you
are and so it's like we're in this
Society where men make more than women
but women are fatter than men and I know
they'll use the stat and they'll be like
some women under 30 in cities make more
okay fair but over a lifetime men tend
to make more and I think it's true
because men over
you know I think men like want to work
longer like in their 40s 50s women are
like if someone is knocking and moaning
at home it'll do wonders for your work I
think
but also like yeah I hear you like men
are driven by by sex a lot more than
women are therefore women's looks are
more important than a man's looks men we
kind of rely on women loving us to still
want to [__] us rather than our physical
attraction you know we think bringing
home the bacon is actually what should
make a woman want to you know give us
what we want and have you ever had a
moment in a relationship where someone's
hit you with some home truths and you
found that hard to listen to yeah really
can you remember what it was oh actually
oh my gosh one time I tried to make my
ex-boyfriend his favorite meal and he
thought it was so bad oh my gosh it hurt
my feelings so much I worked all day to
make that I'm worked oh I worked the
entire day to make his favorite meal and
I was so proud of it and he said
terrible this is I used to be a pretty
bad cook I'm a lot better now but I used
to be pretty bad and that really wounded
you yeah I was really mad in my
experience I commit to London I started
dating obviously like women aren't like
they're not in a hurry to cook for you
like it's it's a rarity really yeah wow
yeah women in my experience like they
they weren't like any good at cooking
because they've grown up with this like
they all went to University they all
been living yeah yeah
they're not like they live like teenage
boys these girls they're more messy than
me do you know what I'm saying relax I
agree with you you know what I mean I'm
[__] in London essentially because I I
came from old-fashioned mother who
literally like the house was so spotless
you know you've now been in with modern
women it's such a clash for me
um and I guess it must be for you
hanging out with modern women as well
I'm kind of messy to be honest
yeah no I'm trying to work I'm I'm
working on it but I definitely have
messy
um I used to be a pretty bad cook too
but you can attest my cooking's gotten
better right
I cook for the staff actually all the
time you've got some controversial
tweets together should we believe women
who say that they were sexually
assaulted but didn't file a police
report oh yeah um I'm gonna say no no
I'll tell you why so I used to
that was my default like if a girl says
oh I was assaulted oh I would like this
you know my your first instinct she's
crying she's sad she's emotional
whatever your first instinct is to
believe her and I used to on my show
until I started asking questions like
just as follow-up so she would say this
happened and I would say well did you
file a police report no
um but it to me it doesn't make sense
why are you coming on my podcast if
you're afraid to talk to the police but
you're afraid to talk into a microphone
to Millie I 1.4 million subscribers or
three something like that it just didn't
equate so I just think we're a little
bit too quick to believe women
um without any evidence a lot of these
girls would say my ex-boyfriend that I
dated for this long anyone watching the
show is gonna know who that guy is
and should we just believe her even
though there's no evidence we've no
one's even investigated it just based
off her word and in a way they're kind
of defaming his character and ruining
his reputation and in there because
people will see it right one girl came
on and said that her ex abused her and I
said well did you ever hit him
[Music]
she did and so it's like now you're
you're labeling him as an abuser when
you hit first
so how are you a victim how were you
abused and I just think we don't ask
women questions when they tell these
stories obviously there's some truth in
what you're saying in terms of some
examples you've given the I can't argue
with the toll and then
there's some victims who for them to
come forward and talk to the police
takes a lot of strength and a lot of
years before they can feel like they can
do that do you agree no really if
someone raped me I'm going to the police
someone punches me in the face I want
them to why would I not want to tell the
police I think for you I believe you
because you're very like confident
speaker I had a moment when I was a
young kid where a babysitter touched me
and I didn't say anything for years and
years not because you know it didn't
happen but obviously because
it just never felt
um
right you know I don't know why I didn't
feel like anything like I mean that was
a different you were a kid weren't you
yeah I was a kid so that was a different
example but but I guess the point I'm
making is I've heard some victims talk
about things in a way that I'm like I
get why that would be very traumatic and
talking like you're scared that people
aren't going to believe you it might be
a often is a family member so when you
go to the police you're gonna [__] your
whole family up I mean yeah I could see
your point
um I think there are some cases where
um you know true yes but I I think by
and large should we just believe people
based on their word my answer is no I I
think you need some evidence one of the
trickiest bits is the evidence so if I
rape up in three months ago getting
evidence is very difficult well that's
why I think we should encourage victims
to go to the police that's my opinion I
think we should because you don't want
him to do that to someone else or her
right yeah yeah I hear what you're where
you're coming from I do think that does
take a lot of strength and not like you
are a very strong person that's clear
and and often people right after that
happens they're they're probably their
worst so I would suggest that I'm not
saying people don't lie I mean I've just
covered a story recently where this girl
smashed her own face and with a hammer
did you see that I didn't actually watch
I like saw the articles
smashed her own face in with the hammer
and now is in prison after wrongly
accusing people so that does happen but
equally I do see the other side of it
um yeah I mean my whole point is I just
think we shouldn't have recorded public
opinion A lot of girls will go around
saying that a man abused them or a man
raped them or whatever with no evidence
and now we're in a point where his
entire character is destroyed in that
community and he didn't even get his day
in court if she doesn't like I I hear
you I think for me if if a woman comes
out and goes to social media before she
goes to the police that for me feels I'm
not comfortable with that because if
that happened why are you why are you
going to people before you're going to
the police or even just like going
around telling the whole town about it
so you're gonna tell everyone in town
and you're not afraid to do that but
you're afraid to go to the police it
just doesn't add up yeah yeah I I I I
agree with you on that sense I think
there's some people who probably have
bottled things up for years and wouldn't
tell people like me and you in a public
forum but you're on a public forum and
yet you haven't gone to the police that
doesn't add up yeah especially with this
girl she dated the guy for like six
years so everyone watching knows who it
is wow and you know at first like the
story is oh he abused me and then we ask
more and more questions like one thing
that girls always say is there's bruises
on my arm or something like that and
then you've come to find out well she
there's bruises on your arms because you
were trying to hit him oh and so that's
so then so she's like oh he held me down
so it's I don't know what's your take on
women hitting sorry on men hitting women
back after they've been hit I think from
a moral perspective I feel like if you
hit someone you should expect to get hit
back I could understand why men avoid it
because
what's that gonna like the police are
gonna take her side so what kind of
relationship do you see yourself having
do you think you will because this whole
production company has really taken off
and I don't see it slowing down and
it'll be very hard for a man to come
into your life and be like yo you're
getting in the kitchen now love like how
do you imagine that's going to work out
I really hope to be in a relationship
where I can trust my husband's
leadership
um and I want to cook I want to cook for
my family to be honest that's important
to me do you think you'd ever walk away
from all of that that you've created now
just to be a mother and give it up or do
you think you'll balance it if push came
to shove I would give it up what does
push contest mean if I felt like I could
not raise a family and do this I would
give it up right okay I've got one last
question that I like to ask people how
would you like to be remembered
um
at the end of my life I'd like to be
remembered as a good friend and a good
mother and a good daughter
the great answer yeah thank you very
much that was Pearl on the true Geordie
podcast do check her Channel out if you
want to watch people having great
debates I really enjoy it and uh yeah
I've thoroughly enjoyed having you on
thanks thank you for having me this is a
lot of fun yeah I'd love to do it again
sometime yeah for sure we should you
should come out on a show yeah I'd love
to yeah that'd be great yeah no doubt
come on come on with the feminists yeah
foreign
[Music]